this week we're talking all about
machine learning the hardware making
recommendations and how tensorflow
Enterprise can optimize your business
I'm mark and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news google cloud offers a range
of solutions for enterprise situations
allowing customers to choose what fits
best for them even down to the chip
recently Google cloud TP used broke the
scalability records for inference adding
to the previous record-breaking success
for learning so if cutting edge deep
learning workloads are a core part of
your business you'll want to take a look
at cloud TP use it's nothing unusual to
recommend ways to optimize your cloud
infrastructure and security settings but
what is unusual is how Google cloud uses
machine learning to power our
suggestions one such tool is the cloud
Identity and Access Management
recommender which we've cracked open for
a behind the scene looks at the machine
learning that powers it tensorflow is
one of the most popular machine learning
frameworks which was made universally
useful with the launch of tensorflow
enterprise and now we're expanding on
that enterprise grade support and
performance with improvements in reading
data from cloud storage and bigquery the
speed of getting data from storage to
the ml training process can be critical
for AI enabled businesses so we're here
to optimize cube con and cloud native
Khan 2019 is happening right now
November 18th through 21st in San Diego
California if you want to learn more
about cloud solutions of all sorts you
should come registration is still open
and it'll be available on site if you
want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link have any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you